this video is sponsored by skillshare
showbiz modern art cooking dance these
are all ways that human beings express
themselves through creativity there are
a million ways to get started on your
creative journey but one of the best
ways by far is skillshare it's an online
learning community with thousands of
videos dedicated to starting or
deepening your passion whether it be for
acting editing videos or drawing works
of art i especially love classes like
productivity for creatives by thomas
frank since they're full of super useful
advice for people like me and everyone
of skillshare's growing number of videos
are specifically curated for learning
only meaning there are never any ads in
the videos themselves if you're
interested in taking that next step for
your passion click that link in the
description below the first 1000 people
to do so will get an entire month of
skillshare for free and now on to the
video
hey everyone bandit here look at this
picture i found of a baby isn't it cute
this baby human well guess what it's two
and a half years old you know what else
is that old the trailer for breath of
the wild too the one that broke the
entire freaking internet and served as a
catapult for channels like mine to rise
from nothingness on this merciless
youtube algorithm released two and a
half years ago and after all this time
we're still calling it breath of the
wild 2 or the sequel to breath of the
wild if you think you're better than
everyone and i think that's pretty weird
and all things considered probably means
that the name of the next zelda game is
not only going to be something extremely
impactful to the series but also
something that we might already be able
to deduce at least a couple
possibilities anyway and i might be
overthinking it but hey what else is new
now you might be thinking the fact that
we don't know the sequel's name yet
isn't that weird because it isn't the
first time nintendo has announced a
sequel to one of their hit games much
less a sequel to a smash hit zelda game
and it's also not the first time
nintendo has used a code word in the
place of their zelda video game sequel
name in order to keep the suspense alive
and you'd be right because that's
exactly what they did with what is
perhaps the most famous zelda sequel
majora's mask originally when the first
zelda came out in the ripe year of 1987
the arcade legends massive success
prompted miyamoto and the crew to come
up with a direct sequel to the original
and since it was the second game it was
appropriately announced as and called
zelda 2 with the subtitle the adventure
of link not much suspense here but fast
forward past a couple zelda games in
1991 and 1993 and eventually we were
gifted with the legend of zelda ocarina
of time the greatest game of all time
in my opinion anyway ocarina of time was
another huge smash hit and obviously
following suit with what they did in the
wake of zelda's massive success a decade
earlier they decided once again to make
a direct sequel only this time they used
a code word when announcing the game for
some reason one year after ocarina of
time was gifted to the world in may of
1999 the japanese gaming magazine
famitsu declared that nintendo had
another zelda expansion planned that
would utilize the nintendo 64's 64 dd
storage expansion and this mysterious
project was code named ura zelda which
roughly translates to the hidden zelda
or zelda behind
and one month later in june nintendo
themselves announced that a playable
demo of something called zelda gaiden
would be playable at the nintendo space
world exhibition in august originally
most people and media outlets assumed
that ura zelda and zelda gaiden were one
of the same because of the code names
and the fact that they were announced
merely a month apart from one another
but according to some ign and game
informer articles from 1999 miyamoto
confirmed in august of 99 that the two
were actually separate projects then in
march of y2k nintendo officially
announced that zelda gaiden's actual
name was the legend of zelda majora's
mask with ura zelda assumedly being
eventually released as the ocarina of
time master quest but that's debatable
depending on who you talk to anyway i
recapped all of that to say that
nintendo has famously kept sequels of
major zelda games under the wraps of
code names before but with two big
differences to what they're doing now
with breath of the wild too in the first
place the official name majora's mask
was revealed to the public less than a
year after it was announced under the
code name zelda gaiden now it is true
that nintendo was rushing the game for
other reasons that i won't go into at
this time but even so they announced the
name of the new zelda game before the
hype began to die down which
unfortunately is a bit of what we're
seeing these days with breath of the
wild sequel since you know it's been two
and a half years and all and nintendo
knows this because this isn't their
first rodeo with a sequel in this very
game series so letting the hype die
feels deliberate which leads me to the
second bigger and more mysterious
difference which is that they actually
did tell us why we don't know the name
just yet in an interview with ign this
year nintendo of america's senior
marketing manager bill trynan said that
the name hasn't been announced yet
because it would give too much away and
that's it that's all they said but see
this is why the lack of a name is so
weird to me because let me ask you a
question when have you ever bought a
zelda game or any game for that matter
without knowing the title of said game
and when you knew the title did it give
anything important away about the game
itself i mean sure titles like ocarina
of time kind of spoil the fact that
there's an ocarina of time in the game i
guess and a title like breath of the
wild spoils the fact that link has no
toothbrush to cure his wild breath with
but are either of these or any of the
zelda titles actually spoiling anything
of significance about the story twilight
princess minish cap the wand of gamelon
in each case we're still left like 99.9
in the dark about what's going to happen
in the game but that's just it see since
the game itself hasn't been experienced
yet it doesn't matter what the zelda
game is called because you don't know
what it relates to yet take majora's
mask for example before you play the
game if you read that title you know
that there's a mask that belongs to an
individual named majora but who's majora
you don't know in skyward sword there's
a sword pointing towards the sky but why
does that even matter in literally every
zelda game up until now because the
point of reference for the title is from
within the game itself before you've
played the game you therefore cannot be
spoiled right so bringing this back to
breath of the wild 2 since we really
don't know much about the game itself
there's only one remaining reason as to
why nintendo would consider the title a
spoiler and that would be if it pertains
to something we already know logically
speaking that's the only reason they
would consider it a spoiler and be
afraid of people reading too much into
it so this begs the question what is the
name about well speaking honestly
there's no way we could possibly nail
that down for sure but i think we can
narrow it down to a set number of
possibilities based on what little we do
know about the sequel it's true that the
vast majority of what we've been shown
about the sequel to breath of the wild
is completely mysterious to all of us so
far but there are some things that we've
seen that we can relate to the first
possibility is that it spoils something
about the timeline as a whole namely the
end of the timeline it's no secret that
breath of the wild's timeline placement
has long been debated amongst fans since
it kind of alludes to having taken place
in all of the timelines at different
points in the game but one thing is for
sure it is the most futuristic zelda
game on the timeline meaning it takes
place after all the others regardless of
which specific timeline it is within and
since this new game is going to be a
sequel not prequel to breath of the wild
logically it will then be the new most
futuristic zelda game but that alone is
not the spoiler what would be a spoiler
is if it implied that as the latest game
in the timeline it was also the last
which could be assumed for several
different reasons if it were named
something like the legend of zelda the
end of time or the curse's end or the
last battle or something similar i could
see that giving quite a bit away about
the story of the game or at least just
enough so that fans like me would go
crazy with theories the second
possibility is that it would imply
something about a certain beloved
returning villain that we've seen in the
game so far ganondorf think about it
from everything we know about the sequel
the only thing so far that attaches it
to the older games other than breath of
the wild is ganondorf and we have
several reasons to believe that this is
going to be possibly his biggest and
most notable appearance since ocarina of
time since ganondorf has been the most
recurring villain across the entire
series it makes sense that he's one of
the most recognizable zelda characters
of all time and his appearance in a new
game alone is enough to bring levels of
hype that you've never seen before case
in point the trailer for breath of the
wild 2 there was not a single shot in
that trailer that was revealed to us by
accident and ganondorf's appearance in
both trailers obviously indicates that
he's going to be a huge part in the game
since this is a widely accepted
assumption across the fanbase it would
therefore be a spoiler if the title were
to reveal something about ganondorf
perhaps similarly something about his
end or final appearance in the series
something like the end of the demon king
or ganon's demise
that one has some implications so anyway
to recap everything i've said in this
video i think the fact that nintendo has
been holding out on revealing the name
to us for literally years at this point
and the fact that they said it contains
spoilers about the sequel means that
logically it can only be about one of
two things the timeline or ganondorf i'm
pretty sure that if it were named
something about literally anything else
in the entire game like revenge of the
stone taluses we'd be completely in the
dark but of course that's just my theory
what do you guys think is the sequel to
breath of the wild going to be named
something that gives away a spoiler
about the structure of the zelda
timeline as a whole or perhaps even the
big man himself or is it something else
entirely and nintendo is just holding
out on us for the giggles let me know in
the comments below also thank you so
much for watching please consider
leaving a like below if you liked the
video and to get it spread around to
another zelda fan just like you and me
and subscribe if you haven't already for
lots of videos to come about your
favorite games that's all i've got for
this one so as always i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day this is mass
intended bandit looking forward to
seeing you next time and signing out
peace
[Music]
you